wenn wir jetzt zu einem grausamen
verbrechen in sachsen ein 16 jahre altes
mädchen wird in einem garagenkomplex
einfach abgestochen erliegt später im
krankenhaus ihren verletzungen
die notärzte haben den kern um das junge
leben verloren vom täter noch keine spur
doch was genau ist gestern nachmittag
dort passiert
tödliches drama in einer garage im
ostsächsischen großröhrsdorf ein 16
jähriges mädchen wurde offenbar
niedergestochen polizeibeamte erhielten
ein hinweis über ein streit in einer
garage in der
johann-sebastian-bach-straße
ein mädchen soll schwer verletzt
bewusstlos und blutend am boden liegen
rettungskräfte versuchen die jugendliche
vor ort zu reanimieren
sie wird ins krankenhaus gebracht und
liegt dort ihren verletzungen der
mutmaßliche täter ist noch auf der
flucht laut zeugenaussagen soll er mit
einem messer auf die 16-jährige
eingestochen haben die polizei sucht mit
einem großaufgebot nach ihm auch
fährtenhunde sind im einsatz
die polizei fahndet im zusammenhang mit
der tat nach einem derzeit unbekannten
männlichen tatverdächtigen
zeugen werden gebeten sich bei der
polizei in kamenz oder jeder anderen
polizeidienststelle zu melden zum
derzeitigen motiv oder zu den umständen
des todes kann die polizei derzeit nicht
sagen das ist gegenstand der
ermittlungen zu dem motiv und den
umständen des todes kann die polizei
derzeit nicht sagen das ist gegenstand
der ermittlungen
wie der polizist schon sagte und wir
schalten jetzt zu unserem kollegen marc
savard schinski du bist vor ort in der
sächsischen kleinstadt großröhrsdorf wo
sich alles abgespielt hat was hast du an
einer neuen information wie weit ist die
polizei mit den ermittlungen
ja ich würde jetzt erstmal damit der
zehn dass wir jetzt direkt hier am
tatort sind wir sind hier direkt in der
kleinen stadt großröhrsdorf
7000 einwohner an der johann sebastian
bach straße soll sich diese schreckliche
bluttat
stattgefunden hat und wir gehen jetzt
direkt zum tatort wir sehen diesen
garagenkomplex in diesem garagenkomplex
gestern gegen 15 uhr 45 dort gab es die
erste information
diese schreckliche bluttat sich ereignet
haben ein bisher unbekannter mann oder
ein er vielleicht irgendwann soll eine
16 jährige mit vermutlich ein messer
abgestochen haben wir befinden uns jetzt
hier direkt am tatort die
spurensicherung war gestern den ganzen
abend vor ort und wir sehen jetzt hier
diesen garagenkomplex dort unten
befindet sich auch noch
kies das hatte gestern die polizei hier
gemacht hier war die blutlache ein
erster hat schon eine kerze aufgestellt
und auch noch reste der spurensicherung
sind teilweise hier die polizei
ermittelt hat zum beispiel heute
vormittag daten die müllabfuhr zum
beispiel hier gestoppt um nämlich im
zweifel zwar zu durchsuchen weil
natürlich die möglichkeit besteht dass
der täter der immer noch auf der immer
noch gesucht wird auch vielleicht noch
etwas entsorgt haben könnte stand ist
dass das mädchen hier reanimiert werden
musste und später dann einem umliegenden
krankenhaus
verstorben ist
gewohnt sie soll hier aus der region
stammen wir hatten jetzt auch schon
gehört dass aus der oberschule die hier
vor ort ist bzw auch teilweise schon
kinder nach hause gegangen sind
vermutlich wurden sie informierte das
hat eine ihrer mitschülerinnen
leider gestern hier getötet wurde und
weiß man mehr zum tathergang gab es
streit
das ist derzeit noch
unklar
das ist auch teil der ermittlungen ob es
dafür einen start gegeben habe wir haben
uns heute den ganzen vormittag herrschen
umgehört die ganzen anwohner haben wir
trotz der urzeit bis 1545 mitten am
helllichten tag eigentlich nichts
mitbekommen und hab mich ja auch im
duster das hat hier eigentlich auch noch
nie einen vorfall gegeben sagen sie und
sie finden es einfach gruselig weil
wirklich hier direkt in diesem komplex
direkt umher sind überall
einfamilienhäuser und kleinere
wohnblöcke
der schock das entsetzen über dieses
verbrechen steckt tief matschinsky
vielen herzlichen dank für deine
einschätzungen
[Musik]